- Now, let me say something inflammatory
that's gonna make everyone else react.
(men groan)
(groovy music)
- Just really wanted to see
Asians being represented
as the people that I know in real life.
- Trans people are people
too and we're here.
We've been around.
- [Woman] Going outside
wearing only body paint
is really similar to having insecurities.
- [Man] To grow up in a society,
in a culture that's very
frank about the way you look
changes the way you perceive
your personal relationship with beauty.
- [Woman] The parts of
me that don't fit in
are the parts that make me unique.
- [Man] Learn to love yourself
for more than just your body.
- [Woman] Our bodies, no
matter their size, their shape
their ability...
You know, if you're healthy
and you're feeling good,
then you've got nothing to hide.
- [Woman] This proves
that we need to show more
body inclusivity on fashion
ads because it shows that
you can be beautiful at any size.
- [Woman] I'm most excited
to be outside of my body
and see myself walking
down the runway and say,
like "Hey! That girl's
cool, like, look at her.
She's, like, super confident."
- [Woman] It feels a little
bit strange, obviously, talking
about something as
intimate as masturbation
but I think it's a really healthy thing.
- [Woman] With makeup and without makeup.
And I love both of the side equally.
- No fighting guys.
- [Man] Please turn the light on for us.
(man screams)
- [Man] Every single item
on there is more expensive
than anything I would normally eat.
- [Woman] So I get a fee
because I have no money?
- Yep.
- So you're charging
people for being poor?
- [Narrator] Welcome to Modern Sex.
- Let's put stuff in our mouths.
- [Woman] Had sex for the very
first time pretty recently.
(crowd laughs)
- [Woman] Please just get
me a caramel frappuccino.
- I thought you said they
were too many calories?
- I'm a growing boy.
- [Woman] Is it that
embarrassing to date me
that you gotta hide your face?
- [Man] Simple answer, yes.
(crowd yelling)
- [Man] 'Bout to see if
anybody is ready to try
to beat my world record.
- Little steps.
- You many now kiss the bride.
- Okay.
- Do one of those.
- Whoa!
- Oh my god!
- It's a disaster.
- [Man] I'm here in some friggin dungeon.
- Three.
- Ah (beep).
- Ah!
- We're probably not going to
continue to have sex everyday.
- Fucking just spit on me.
Just spit on me.
(woman yells)
- Oh my gosh.
- I'm bleeding.
- First blood.
(man screams)
(crowd cheers)